Sovereignist,
it is 1 word that we throw away like that in the public debate.
1 label that you want to be as sticky as possible,
1 bit like these corpses
plagued than armies
were thrown over the walls of the cities to
contaminate the inhabitants.
Sovereignist,
under the pen of the telegraphists of power,
became 1 insult.
Why did you do that?
Well,
because it takes
all costs to silence those who denounce the oligarchy,
those who have had
reason for alertness on deindustrialization,
social regression and thees of deregulation,
those who warned against the detour of the
European construction for the benefit of multinationals
specialist in tax optimization and
Social Jumping.
Marianne,
we are logically the target
souvenir.
But let's see,
is the Yaslino and Philippo line,
the supporters of the frexit,
as subtly explained on X
comedian Sophia Haram,
in a hurry to play the gun door.
Historically,
the term sovereignism
was imported from Quebec,
where it designated the
fight against the Canadian federal state,
imported into the current
of the mille-neuf-cent-quatre-vingt-dix s,
in the continuity of the treaty of mastrixte,
to designate what was opposed
to the federal advances of a European Union
more and more distant from the
Treaty of Rome.
Philippe Cégain and Jean-Pierre Chevénement,
social Gaulism and the left
had carried the debate
in mille-neuf-cent-quatre-vingt-douze,
of the democratic problem
that the fact of having sovereignty resided,
that is,
the source of power
elsewhere than in the constitution voted by the people.
Just listen again to Philippe Cégain's speech.
In front of the National Assembly,
May 5 mille-neuf-cent-quatre-vingt-douze,
to understand
that the debate carries
on the legacy of mille-sept-cent-quatre-vingt-neuf
on democracy,
what followed proved him right.
Especially since,
at the time,
they prophesy that it is a one-way ticket,
which is the case.
Point out the countless deleted effects
the dual process
of mastrixte and enlargement to the east
on the French economy.
Don't imply that I believe that a frexid would be
possible or desirable,
it is not,
but to know the causes of deindustrialization,
the refusal
of the French elites to defend
correctly in SMEs,
our agriculture and our industrial flagships in this
economic context that these elites
have themselves forged,
knowing its causes is the only
way to effectively reorient our policy.
Who is carrying this speech today?
Not reasonable people,
from any political family.
François Bayrou,
in our columns,
while defending European construction,
said his distrust
with respect to mechanisms such as voting
by a qualified majority
which could
prevent France from defending its vital interests.
François Bahirou is neither anti-European nor extremist.
He embodies this centrist current that believes in France
and continues to believe that the political debate
does not justify the demonization of the opponent.
We remember the inescapable
editorial by Jean-bani
in the world
explaining on the eve of the 1st round of two thousand and seven
that the Bayrou vote was not a democratic vote.
Why these delusions,
why this need for defamation?
Why these accounts
activists on social networks?
And these messages
of editorialists
excited to sully Marianne by explaining that our
newspaper would be propoutine,
populist and therefore sovereignist,
everyone feels the political climate
is becoming tense,
how much we fall into 1st or
even within the media landscape.
We would like to force citizens to choose between 2 camps,
the National Recapture
or the system as it is.
Jean-Luc Mélenchon,
when he practices excessive clientelism,
when he
compare 1 university director to haichman to
victimize
and denounce 1 censorship that does not bother him at all,
when it is his own troops that he imposes,
serves this project admirably.
The goal?
To
continue again and again
to maintain 1 system that breaks down on all sides
and whose mutual support is reduced
like a skin of sorrow.
And to erase for that the impediments to turn in circles,
defending both social justice and secularism,
demonstrating
tirelessly that the Defense of the Republic
and the preservation of the planet
are not compatible with free trade
generalized,
erase them with caricature and anathema,
by stirring the specter of anti-france
agents from abroad.
But these sorcerer's apprentices do not understand
obviously not only by using the same springs
populists
than the extremes they claim to fight,
by radicalizing their troops in the same way,
by pushing back to extremes
all reasonable opponents,
by de all political debates with a slogan
simplistic,
by to make any
alternative political proposal,
they pave the road.
From the National Rally,
it would be more than time to
find 1 debate space
in which reasonable people,
attached to honesty
and file control,
can exchange their arguments
on how to
serve the interests of France
and to preserve the promises of the Republic.
Because the subject
is not whether you are anist or not,
if you are pro or anti-European,
but to ask the question of
real conditions of democracy
and how independence can be guaranteed
of France and Europe,
of France within Europe
in a context of clash of empires.
The rest is up for political debate
what the Marseillais vs the rest of the world
are for.